hello everybody hopefully you can hear
me hopefully everything's set up kind of
in a rush this morning setting things up
a little bit three minutes late I
thought I'd be five so you know that's
good
right I noticed in the comments that
there were some people that were upset
by my title saying that it's not fair
for me to say the creationists lie when
you know most people live from time to
time well we're gonna be looking into
that we're gonna be looking into how it
is specifically that creationists have
been lying with numbers using math to
toll eyes but I'm also going to point
out how common this is how ubiquitous
this is and also how not only do we lie
with with math do we lie with numbers
but we accidentally deceive ourselves
and it is kind of hard when you're
looking at someone who's deceiving their
audience with numbers it's kind of hard
to tell if they've deceived themselves
as well or if they're actually
deliberately lying so for those that are
upset with me for saying that
creationists are lying with numbers I
suppose you could make the argument that
you know we can't say for sure that
they're lying unless we actually know
the intents and you know things inside
their brains and that's fair but false
truths are often communicated with math
and there's a lot of reasons that this
works so well or this that this happens
so often
first off everybody trusts math you know
all of us who've learned how math works
we know that two plus two equals four
and we know that you can't but you can't
change that fact that's a mathematical
fact and it can't be changed and so when
we have numbers that back up the claims
that we make this gives our claim a
really solid sense of authority early
solid sense of truthfulness and because
of that you see people use numbers and
arguments all the time from issues on
politics you know if you're arguing gun
violence for example maybe you're
pro-gun maybe you're anti-gun you're
going to look for numbers that support
your position and you're going to use
those we've we have in the news this
with Donald Trump the you know
alternative fax this idea in alternative
fax are usually based on using different
number sets to make an argument so your
your numbers can actually be correct
they can be accurate but you're using a
very specific number set it's different
than your opponent and so your fax the
facts that you're using our alternative
fax to those used by your opponent so
this is something that when it was first
brought up in the campaign I can't
believe I can't remember which if it was
Donald Trump himself or one of his
campaign people that first book forth
this alternative fax type thing but we
all laughed at it like you're an idiot
there's no such things that's
alternative facts but actually if you
look the way that people use numbers to
make arguments you'll find that you
could say that there are alternative
facts there are in any especially any
complex issue you can look at specific
sets of facts and leave others out often
called cherry-picking to come to cut to
one conclusion and you can do the other
on the opposite side of the argument and
this is how most arguments and politics
happen when when they're using numbers
is they're they're cherry-picking the
data and this cherry-picking numbers is
one way in which we can lie with math
but the other way that people can lie
with math is by simply doing story
problems wrong usually if you screw up
on your actual math people will call you
out on it but if you screw up on the
story problem most people won't notice
because we're we suck it to make story
problems so I've got some slides
prepared to show to talk about to big to
big things that to big lies that are
often put forth in the creationist
movement that involve numbers involved
math so let me just share my screen here
we're gonna see infinite screen for a
second
all right hopefully you can all see my
slides now so how creationists lie with
math and indeed how how most people lie
with math I'd I want to point out that
all of us I guarantee that you currently
believe something that's false because
you got tricked by some weird math I'm
sure that I currently believe something
that's false because I got tricked by
weird math and maybe the person that
tricked me did it on purpose or maybe
they were actually tricked with the
numbers as well so this is extremely
common it's not just creationist to do
this but here are two two big claims
math shows it is impossible for protein
to form randomly therefore the origin of
life is impossible this is a super
common claim it sits in videos all over
the internet it's in multiple books
especially popularized by the
intelligent design community they've got
a bunch of stuff on this and then the
second claim is that math shows that the
fossil record is nearly complete
therefore all gaps that we find in the
fossil rack our fossil record show
created kinds they are evidence for
creation so gaps in the fossil record
are evidence for creation because math
shows us that the fossil record is
nearly complete
so I'm gonna just to make sure real
quick that everyone's hearing me I'm
gonna go through the comments here
sorry you're now looking at my infinite
screens looks like all is well
everyone's able to hear me and stuff
okay back to my slides so these are
those two claims that we're gonna be
looking at but again alternative facts
are found everywhere I was looking at
just arguments in facebook just
yesterday to kind of look for examples
of people that are doing this that are
using math to lie to each other and I
saw an argument between a vegan and a
meat-eater and you know the vegan
argument is that by eating a plant-based
diet you're being nicer to animals
that's that's one of the arguments for
being vegan there's a bunch of other
arguments for being vegan as well no
just so you know my my personal stance
on it I think that you know I am a an
omnivore I eat meat from time to time I
eat much much less now than I used to
but I do believe that vegans are in
general correct eating less meat or even
eating no meat if you look at the data
it really is better for the environment
it's typically better for the person
unless they have certain metabolic
issues in which case some people
actually do need to eat meat and it's in
general it's far better for the
environment far better for the
environment in general to eat a vegan
diet than to eat a omnivorous or now
there's the new popular carnivorous diet
that's coming out but the argument that
I saw being made on Facebook was that
one loaf of bread kills roughly one
Mouse one pound of beef only kills 112
hundredths of a cow and they they based
these numbers off of this article right
here called ordering the vegetarian meal
there's more animal blood on your hands
and this is a this is an article that
breaks down the numbers of how many mice
are killed when wheat is being harvested
and then how many mice and rats are
killed later
protect grain when it's in being stored
in grain silos before it's made into
products to go to stores and if you do
the math well based on the numbers in
this article it is about one mouse that
dies per loaf of bread that that is made
and so you could say you know the
sentient being known as a mouse is
equally as important it can suffer just
as much as a cow
therefore eating bread is worse than
eating beef
well the convenient fact that's left out
in this equation is that most beef
especially beef in America is grain fed
and if you use those exact same numbers
that were used in that article producing
one pound of beef kills 13 mice and then
more rats are killed in the
slaughterhouse because we and these
numbers are not included in the article
so I don't know what they would actually
be but slaughterhouses have to kill rats
because rats love eating meat and so
your slaughtering 13 mice per pound of
beef produced because of all the grain
that's required to feed those the cattle
and then you're killing an unknown
number of rats as well in the
slaughterhouse and then in the places
it's store beef and so on before it's
sold and then this number right here
that one pound of beef only kills 112
hundredths of a cow that's assuming that
every pound of a cow equals meat that's
not true there's only about 480 pounds
of beef in a it had 1,200 pound cow so
you can see that the math here is
completely screwed up and if you're
living on bread instead of meat
especially the way that meat is produced
in America you are dramatically more
kind to wildlife than if you eat beef
instead so this is one way that people
are lying with math and the really
interesting thing about this is that if
you feel guilty for hurting animals when
you see this math showing that that
bread is more deadly than cows you don't
want to question it because it tells you
what you already want to hear it it
eases your pain like oh I'm not such a
monster I'm I'm saving the lives of mice
right so there's this you see this in
arguments on politics all the time you
see this we always want to agree with
the numbers that support our
pre-existing beliefs we are horrible at
looking at things you know from a
neutral perspective so that was that's
one of the early common examples well
what not a really common example an
example I found just in my Facebook feed
the other day when I was looking at this
arguing for eating meat and then another
example that I found was that you know
this is my just moved to Canada and
Canada just legalized marijuana and I'm
seeing a lot of people arguing about you
know should everybody legalize marijuana
and there was a study I believe is 2017
well along here it is 2016 saying that
they continue the continuity of cannabis
use and violent offending over the life
course that's a really weird title but
what what that what the paper is saying
is that long term marijuana use is
linked to violence among people studied
in it in england and this is a really
interesting study because it was over a
50-year period where they followed these
people and they found that people who
consistently smoked marijuana
end up committing violent crimes they're
they're far more likely to commit
violent client crimes as adults after
you know 20 to 30 use 8 20 to 30 years
of consistent marijuana use and the
people who wrote this paper said look
marijuana is causing violence but this
is so hilarious because to anyone that
knows anything about the black market
and how it works you know in England
marijuana is illegal and so if you want
to buy marijuana and use it in England
you have to buy it from a drug
who is working in the black market and
if you are a drug dealer working in the
black market guess what if you get
robbed if your client Rob's you if
another drug dealer Rob's you you cannot
go to the police you cannot file a
report you have no power to get the
state's help if you are injured or
robbed and because of that everybody who
works in the black market has to be
tough they have to project they there
have to be violent or they have to
project that they could be violent if
need be they have to intimidate people
into not robbing them that's the only
way for them to defend themselves the
rest of us when we when we work in a
normal legal job the the threat of
police violence or going to prison is
what stops people from screwing us over
and stealing from us in a normal
day-to-day situation but if you work in
the black market you have to be
aggressive and so if you are smoking
marijuana in England your whole life you
are you're dealing on a regular basis
with either a violent criminal or a
criminal that pretends to be violent and
that's going to rub off on you that's
going to affect the way that you behave
you're constantly interacting with these
people and they might even be
threatening to you from time to time and
it just makes sense that that alone
could be the actual cause for this
slight increase in violence among pot
users in England and that was not
controlled for in the study and it's
really funny because because if you look
at interviews of the researchers that
did the study they're saying we
controlled for every every relevant
thing be controlled for socio-economic
class and so on and so forth but when
you look at the paper they did not
control for the fact that you know
people who buy marijuana are doing so
illegally and therefore have to deal
with violence on a regular basis you
this study in order to be accurate would
have to be done in a country where
marijuana is legal and has been legal
throughout the course of the study until
I get data like that I'm going to say
that this is lying with math
you know we we need data the controls
for you know this situation that I just
put forth so lying with math is super
common it's not just creationists that
do that and it's not just the uneducated
people that these are these are
top-notch researchers that that are
lying with math on accident you know I
don't think they're trying to lie with
math but they're they've made mistakes
they fooled themselves into believing
something that's might be false it might
be true
maybe long-term cannabis use does lead
to violence but they're their research
can't really prove a causal link there
so okay so now we get to the creationist
claims here this is one from the book
the nature of nature by William demske
and William demske is one of the big
guys in the intelligent design community
and in his book he says that the chance
of building a single functional protein
of 150 amino acids from scratch by
chance is 10 to the or 10 to the power
of 164 so that's that's your chances of
doing it if you just keep on randomly
creating new sequences of amino acids
you're gonna have to do that 10 to ^ 164
before you get a functional protein and
this is based on math done by real
researchers that are that we're doing
life origins research in the past and
these types of calculations were
important for us to figure out you know
when we're studying the origin of life
some things happen by chance some things
evolve through descent with modification
acted upon by by selection some things
are directed by natural selection in
some way or another and what sorts of
things would it be reasonable for us to
assume happen by chance and what sorts
of things would have to have happened
under direction of natural selection and
this really helps us you know piece
together
our thoughts and and try and try and
solve this really crazy puzzle how did
life on earth emerge and by the way this
is not a salt puzzle we're still working
on this and so these types of
calculations were really important
earlier on and a bunch of issues around
these have been solved but the
intelligent design people don't want you
to know that they're hiding all of the
solutions that have been solved to this
but then you know William Dempsey goes
on to say to put this number in
perspective there are ten to the power
of 65 atoms in the galaxy and so when
you realize that you realize that for us
to expect that proteins functional
proteins came about from scratch by
chance this is a ridiculously stupid
thing to believe right like that
that can't happen a functional protein
of 150 amino acids is not going to be
merge and have function so we need
another explanation for the origin of
long amino acid sequences and this claim
is repeated over and over and over again
in videos like this this is a video on
YouTube called origin probability of a
single protein forming by chance and it
goes on to say that because this math is
true and this math is true these numbers
are accurate and I'll show you what
they're based on here in a second
because that math is correct those
equations are correct the origin of life
is completely impossible now let's see
and I add the slide it shows you miss
that I did I forgot to add the slide
that explains oh no sorry this is it so
this this is a slide that shows the
three different probability equations
that are added together to make that
that big probability number so this
number of 10 to the power of 164 that
comes from these three different issues
and the origin of proteins
the the chance of making 150 amino acid
sequence with only peptide bonds is 10
to the power of 45 I wonder if I should
explain to you what that even means
basically for those that don't know a
protein which is a functional unit
inside of a cell proteins and modern
cells are pretty big they're typically
between 150 amino acids long they're
made out of amino acids a protein is
made of amino acids it's a chain of
amino acids and the smaller proteins in
our body are about 150 amino acids long
the larger ones can be you know they can
meet thousands of amino acids long and
these chains form through peptide bonds
and if you have two amino acids they can
actually bond to each other in multiple
different ways one of those bond types
is a peptide bond and so the chance of
getting 150 amino acids to bond with
each other all using a peptide bond is
extremely rare so that alone is
difficult then the chance of using only
left-handed amino acids you can have
left-handed amino acids and right-handed
amino acids for most of the 20 amino
acids used in life but living cells only
use left handed amino acids they never
use right-handed amino acids so the
chances of doing that because you've got
two options is 10 to the power of 45
it's actually that that number is
actually a little bit wrong because not
all amino acids have chirality but
anyway it's pretty close
oops and then the chance sorry my slides
are freaking out and then the chance of
making a stable e folded protein 150
amino acids long is 10 to the power of
75 so yet you you put those all together
and you get this number of n to the
power of 164 so that that last number
most protein sequences are not stable in
water they will not fold properly and
they will they'll float to the surface
or sometimes they'll sink to the bottom
of
a liquid that they're that they're
floating in and so amino acid or
proteins need to fold in order to be
active inside of a cell and there's
actually another there's other reasons
why proteins need to fold so he's saying
that if you if you want a protein it's
150 M nos as long the chance of getting
it to fold just by random chance is 10
to the power of 75 yeah add all these
together it's a ridiculously improbable
number well every single one of these
issues has already been well studied by
scientists studying the origin of life
and we already have solutions to all of
these weird problems so we know for
example how abiotic systems can sort
molecules by chirality by left
handedness or right handedness we
already know there's extensive
literature and you can read an overview
of it here in this article we already
know how normal natural systems can sort
molecules by chirality so this is
already a solved problem we don't know
exactly how it happened in the origin of
life but we know many ways in which it
could have happened in the origin of
life and so this this middle number here
the chance of left-handed amino acids
that is completely irrelevant to the
origin of proteins furthermore we don't
even believe that proteins were the
first functional molecules in life a
bulk of the evidence shows us that the
first functional molecules in life were
chains of RNA or chains of a chemical
similar to RNA and this is one of many
papers that talks about this this this
paper talks about the ancestral ribosome
the ancestral ribosome was a pure RNA
based functional molecule and what it
did is it actually took amino acids in
its surrounding and it stuck them
together using pepper
bonds that's that was what the function
of the ancestral ribosome was and so
this paper actually knocks out these
other two or this first number here so
the chance of amino acid sequences
coming together and peptide bonds well
if you've already got a ribosome a
primitive ribosome it's already doing
that it's solving that problem for us so
that first number is irrelevant and then
yeah its ribosomes form much easier than
functional ribosomes form sorry
functional ribozymes so functional
molecules made of RNA form much easier
in prebiotic experiments then functional
proteins do because they don't require
the really complex folding in order for
things to be functional a a chain of RNA
will actually fold simply based on its
its base pairing with itself and to
learn more about that I have this video
called what is the RNA world hypothesis
and it shows you how different RNA
chains can form and how they can fold
into complex three-dimensional
structures and how those can have
function so take a look at that video
what is the RNA world hypothesis if you
want more information on that this paper
the origin evolution and structure of
the protein world this talks a lot about
protein folding and other issues and how
different prebiotic environments would
have solved these problems instead of
creating a hundred and fifty long one
hundred and fifty nucleotide long
peptide need 150 nucleotide long sorry
Wow
my brain this morning I'm sorry folks I
did not have coffee the 150 long amino
acid protein there's in the origin of
why if we were we had these really small
proteins
with maybe just one fold in them and
these can grow here's a paper talking
about how these small proteins can grow
through a combination with other small
folded proteins so that you don't need
to start with a hundred and fifty amino
acid long protein that can fold you can
start with much smaller proteins and the
probability of these emerging by chance
is extremely high compared to the those
numbers from that they creationists are
using and here's another paper again you
can look up all these papers read them
and you'll understand that everything
that these creationists are doing this
this statement that the chance of
building a single functional protein of
150 amino acids from scratch by chance
is ten to the power of one hundred sixty
four this is an example of people
failing to accurately do story problems
they are neglecting all of the data that
we have
they are neglecting the actual theories
that we actually have about the origin
of life they are creating a straw man
theory that we actually think that
functional proteins had to emerge from
scratch that are at least 150 amino
acids long that's the straw man theory
that they're attacking their math is
correct but everything about their claim
everything else about it is absolutely
false so there we have it I'm gonna go
to questions real quick to see if we
have any
shannon asked will there be links to
those papers in the description later
yes I'll do that I just was running late
and didn't have time to put them in here
let's see any other questions that have
been directly sent to me on this protein
folding issue a lot of people are
talking about marijuana and violence
what do cows like to eat when they're
high this is what I get for talking
about marijuana and meat and the start
of my presentation
rationale mind says proteins don't have
to be stable folded to be functional
intrinsically disordered proteins can
also be functional yet that is true but
we in the study of the origin of
proteins we do care quite a bit about
protein folding because it seems to have
happened really early on if you look at
the ribosome so the ribosome is this
giant it's one of the few molecular
machines in our bodies that's still just
made of RNA for the most part all of its
functional bits are made of RNA and we
can actually look at the ribosome and
find which parts of it are most ancient
at least there's there's good reason to
think that we're able to actually parse
out which parts of it are most ancient
and it's really interesting because the
ribosome all of its functional bits are
made of RNA so this which gives gives
credence to the RNA world hypothesis
right but it's stabilized by little
micro proteins and actually modern rnas
have pretty complex proteins also added
to them
really complex proteins in some cases
but when we look at the really ancient
parts of the ribosome
the proteins that are in there they're
not folded proteins they're really
they're really small proteins that
simply attach to the ribosome and allow
it to stabilize itself excuse me they
allow it to be stable and so we think
that a lot of the early functional
proteins simply they weren't functional
on their own they only were functional
and they were only were stable because
they were bound to chains of RNA and
other molecules in their environment so
that is true we don't need folded
proteins nice stable folded proteins in
order to get function there's lots of
different ways to get functional
proteins and again when we look at the
ribosome it seems like the early
proteins that existed in life were not
folded so and they were also very small
they were 150 amino acids long
so she'll reptile says do scientists
know how RNA rised from scratch or rose
from scratch we don't we have there some
people will say that we had we do and
actually there's a research group in
England that's found ways that RNA can
be produced abiotic ly and they found a
nice way that that can happen the
problem is that's it's really hard to
imagine a natural environment that would
have produced RNA at the level needed at
the concentrations needed in order to
give rise to the RNA world using the D
models that have been found so far that
the methods that have been found so far
that that RNAs are produced naturally so
this is this is the big mystery in the
RNA world is how did the first RNA
chains come about how did the first RNA
nucleotides come about and then how do
they form chains and then what exactly
was required for those change to
replicate so there's there's a lot of
mysteries still in the RNA world
hypothesis and a lot of this seems to be
I would say the most promising research
on this is in the metabolism first view
and I'll be doing some videos for stated
clearly about the metabolism first view
essentially what this is is that very
simple molecules very simple very common
molecules can form these cyclical
reactions that end out end up spitting
out much more complex molecules as
byproducts of their own behavior and
these are these are cyclical catalytic
reactions that happen and we know that
they happen in natural environments all
the time and we can we're actually
starting to study these and these things
can evolve in a way that's slightly
different than Darwinian evolution they
evolve they evolve kind of in the way
that an ecosystem evolves where there's
not actually descent with modification
that's happening there's kind of a
growth and change that's happening so
it's really interesting field of
research the the metabolism first view
of the origin of life and I'll put it in
a paper I'll link to a paper about that
or an article about that that's really
good that I found too it gives you kind
of an overview of that but it it is
looking like RNA either emerge from a
simpler molecule that was similar to RNA
or it emerged as the byproduct of some
sort of primitive early metabolic system
so all right any more questions on that
it looks like no we've kind of covered
the questions on that so just to
summarize I feel like I've been a little
bit discombobulated in my my thinking
here today or in my been saying things
but the reason that they're that
creationists claim is false about the
proteins is that they they have built a
straw man theory for how proteins
emerged they're ignoring the RNA world
hypothesis they're ignoring all the
discoveries that we made about how
molecules can be naturally sorted by
chirality they're ignoring all of these
different discoveries and they're just
they're running math that really does
work the math really does work but the
story problem is wrong there miss
applying that math they're playing to a
strawman version of of life origins
chemistry so now let's look at the
second question here let me share my
screen again
sure
all right rolling strong okay here we go
so this is from a an article it was
called they call it a paper it was an
article by Jerry Bergman and I've got
the article here it's the evolution of
feathers a major problem for Darwinism
by Jerry Bergman and this is I guess
this is considered a scientific paper by
the creationists because he kept
referring to it he keeps referring to it
as a paper not only that means it's a
peer-reviewed type thing in his paper he
says that there are nine thousand living
species of birds that are now known all
of which have a very unique skeletal
morphology yet only 45 extinct bird taxa
have ever been identified so what he's
saying is that there's 9,000 birds today
only 45 extinct bird taxa that have been
identified sorry 9000 species of bird
that number is actually currently wrong
there's over 10,000 species of bird that
we now have named but I think when he
was writing this that was probably
accurate he goes on to say this is
strong evidence that that relatively few
types of non modern birds have existed
throughout history so he's saying that
the fact that there's only 45 extinct
species we know of means that there just
weren't very many species beyond what we
see today this conclusion is supported
by the fact that uh 329 living families
of terrestrial vertebrates fully 79%
have been found as fossils as have
ninety seven point seven percent of the
forty-three living terrestrial
vertebrate orders so what he's making it
sound like is that because we have
ninety 97% of all orders are are found
in the fossil record that means that you
know all all the species that exist must
have
discovered in the fossil record all the
species that ever existed must have
already been found he's using this
number 97% if you don't know how
phylogeny works and you read this the
interpretation that you will get is that
97% of all species that ever lived on
earth have been discovered already in
the fossil record therefore any gaps
that we see in the fossil record
represent true gaps they represent not
just you know the fossil record is
impartial but they they represent that
life fits into these nice neat
categories that we see today in living
organisms so you know birds are the only
animals that have feathers for example
and so that we don't see birds that are
transitioning from non feathers to
feathers in modern animals today and if
you believe what this guy is suggesting
that 97% of all organisms are already
been discovered well you're gonna
believe that that there is no transition
of feathers in the fossil record and
you're gonna believe that without
looking you know you just you think
about these numbers and you just accept
that well what he's doing the
mathematical trick that he's doing it
and a lot of creationists do this too
here's a family tree that I drew really
fast
pardon my sloppiness here and here we
see species genus family order class
phylum kingdom domain and then life and
so this is how how life is structured
throughout evolutionary history by the
way these are upside-down my my tree is
going in the opposite order as the
graphic on the left again I didn't have
time to fix this this morning I
apologize but if we color coat my my
tree here we see that on the top this
color represents the species color down
here we see then on the top there are 18
species represented in the street we see
that there are let's see 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 families or sorry 9 genus
in orange here there are four families
in yellow and there are three orders in
green so what paleontologists tell us is
that fossilization is extremely rare so
when we find gaps in the fossil record
the reason for this is that most
organisms that have lived on earth and
then died they don't become fossils and
we actually know this by actually
observing animals die and whether or not
they become fossils when I was a kid I
used to walk around I have to have to
walk really far to the bus stop and to
the park that I always just like to go
to after school and I was fascinated in
watching roadkill it was this long
country road I'd walked down and so
there's always something dead on the
side of the road and I like to watch
roadkill rot because I don't know I'm
weird I guess but what I noticed is that
it only takes a couple of weeks for
something to completely disappear even
the bones will disintegrate they'll be
eaten by bacteria and they'll get messed
up in the Sun other animals will take
them and scatter them and so when I
started learning about fossils it made
perfect sense to me that most organisms
that die don't turn into fossils because
most organisms that die get torn apart
they get torn to pieces and weeks and so
if that's true and we know that it's
true empirically we observe it true that
most things that die are not fossilized
if that's true and then if if you
consider the fact that most things that
do fossil eyes never get discovered by
scientists it's very rare for an
organism to be found as a fossil so here
I've got three organisms that I'm gonna
say fossilized in my what did I say 18
possible species here well if we look at
the math
if just three out of 18 species
fossilized that's only 17% but look at
the genre how many the genus of animals
well that's three out of nine are
represented in the fossil record you see
because there's nine genre and three of
them are accounted for and then for
families we have three out of four
families are accounted for even though
we only found three individuals that
fossilized and four orders that's 100%
100% of the orders are represented here
in this graph and so you see that when
he when he makes this statement nine
thousand living species of birds are
known all of which have a very unique
skeletal morphology yet only 45 extinct
bird taxa have ever been identified in
the fossil record we identify things by
genus only we don't identify things by
species so he's making a jump from
species to Gina's here without really
telling his audience that's what he's
doing then he makes a jump again this is
strong evidence that that relatively few
types of non modern birds have existed
throughout history this conclusion is
supported by the fact that of 329 living
families of terrestrial vertebrates
fully 79% have been found as fossils
again that 79% is just an artifact of
math working on a family tree he jumped
from species to families so he's saying
you know we only forty five out of nine
thousand species but now seventy-nine
percent of families are accounted for
and 97 percent of living terrestrial
orders are accounted for and so he's
using a very sneaky math trick to make
it seem like the fossil record is
complete when actually the fossil record
is not at all complete very very few
things fossilized that said throughout
history our history of studying fossils
we have found gaps
filling essentially every single major
transition the the transitions of
animals that you would be familiar with
soul and animals the only transitions
that we really don't have are the
transitions of bats and their
preflighted ancestors so we don't have a
nice transition showing the evolution of
flight in bats we do have a really nice
transition now of showing the evolution
of flight and in birds and the evolution
of feathers which is funny enough is
what this article is about he's ignoring
all the fossil evidence that we have
showing both of those things the other
the other transition that we don't have
solid is the transition of turtles so
from completely non shelled organisms to
shell organisms it's in particular the
transition of the shoulder blades going
inside the the ribcage that is not well
understood by the fossil record and the
evolution of bats is not well understood
from the fossil record all the other
transitions the transition from fish to
land animal the transition from reptile
like early organisms to to modern
mammals that transition is very very
clearly shown the transition of whales
from land from land animals a transition
of birds from theropod dinosaurs the
transition of yeah you name it like
we've figured all of this stuff out
we've found fossils that show it even
though the fossil record is so scarce
we've been able to find all of these
transitions it's absolutely spectacular
what we've discovered studying the
fossil record so those are ways in which
two ways in which creationists are using
math to lie again this is a super common
trait in all arguments people people
arguing anything complex will select
specific sets of numbers and use little
math tricks to deceive each other
sometimes they do this on purpose
sometimes sometimes
on accident because they suck at story
problems I think that maybe that last
example where he's using these numbers
to say that the fossil record is
complete I think that might be him
actually getting confused when trying to
do a story problem like a genuine him
not knowing how bath works in context of
the larger picture here maybe he was
actually being deliberately deceitful I
don't know in the case of William demske
to say that he's not deliberately lying
there is really tricky because again he
has to ignore paper after paper after
paper after paper in order to make the
claim that he's making so it's a I mean
I guess the same is true for the fossil
record stuff but yeah that that's it
that's how we lie with numbers we screw
up on story problems and we cherry pick
our datasets that's how we do it that's
how a creationists do it that's how
politicians do it that's how everybody
that's how scientists do it on accident
or on purpose it's something that we all
need to watch out for very carefully
math it gives us a false false set of
confidence in our conclusions because
math can't be questioned right so all
right I'm going to go back to questions
here see if anybody's got any stuff for
me
Sheldrick tell says the the fish to
tetrapod transition is not clear they
found trace fossils long before
Tiktaalik and one of its ancestors so
something important to know when we're
looking at transitional fossils and I've
talked about this I'm trying to think of
the video that I did that talks about
this specifically I think it's either
number 3 or 4 and my talk in my video on
the Ark Encounter I think it's video
number ready number 2 or 3 I talk
specifically about Tiktaalik Tiktaalik
is a really nice fully formed fossil
showing a transitional species between a
fully aquatic animal and a fully
terrestrial animal Tiktaalik is an
animal could go on land and can go in
the water and would be pretty much
equally comfortable in both before
Tiktaalik we don't have full fossils of
such organisms but we do have lots of
trace fossils of them so we know that
they existed before Tiktaalik but
Tiktaalik is the is a really nice
example of one that that was capable of
doing that and we don't know when we
find an organism like Tiktaalik if you
look at the evolutionary trees that that
biologists build with these you'll see
that there's a branch that goes up to
Tiktaalik and then another branch you go
down to a node and then up to modern
tetrapods from that and the reason that
we we draw our evolutionary trees like
that is that we cannot assume that
Tiktaalik is actually the species that
gave rise to all modern tetrapods in
fact it was most likely the case that an
ancestor of Tiktaalik I had two children
one in the giving rise to tektaalik and
the other gave rise to modern tetrapods
as we know them today it's actually very
unlikely the Tiktaalik itself that
species itself gave rise to modern
tetrapods and that's just because of
probabilities which I go into in that
video I believe it's video number two so
does that make sense or did I just
ramble incoherently they're shelled
reptile when when we have these
transitional fossils these series of
transitions were not actually saying
this animal morphed into this we're
saying that this there was a common
ancestor that gave rise to this and then
there's a common ancestor later on that
gave rise to this and so on and so forth
we can't actually say that basal asaurus
gave rise to modern dolphins right most
likely it was an ancestor of baseless
ores that gave rise to come in to modern
dolphins
rationale mine says trace fossils
predate fossil transitional tetrapods
for environmental reasons yeah it's way
easier to preserve a footprint than it
is to preserve an entire animal and and
yes they're stating that the paper that
talks about those the footprints in
Poland that show the tetrapods existed
before
Tiktaalik that paper itself has a
modified phylogeny in it and the other
important thing to know about about
fossils is that a lot of people assume
that the moment we find a fossil in the
fossil record must be the moment that
species emerged and that's of course a
silly idea right so people will will
look at Tiktaalik they'll date the rocks
that atelic was found in and then
they'll assume that oh this year I can't
remember what it is like 300 300 million
years ago or something don't quote me on
that I can't remember when tektaalik
what at what date Tiktaalik has on them
but people will say that oh that is the
the time period that tetrapods emerged
well because fossil is a because
fossilisation is such a rare event we
don't see species as they emerge we see
them as they become dominant in an
environment if your species has already
dominated an environment there's
millions of you that exist the rare
chance of becoming a fossil becomes
greater for you right because there's
millions of you so even something that
happens it's one in a million chance if
there's 10 million of you well you've
got a one in two there's a one in ten
chance that a member from that species
will become a fossil so the fossil
record doesn't show us what species
exists at any given time it shows us
which species are super common at any
given time the only rare exception for
this is in a lager Stetten which will
fossil eyes that you know some sort of
natural catastrophe will bury everything
in one particular ecosystem right away
and in those cases you can actually see
pretty much all the organisms that were
alive in that little in that little
region that got buried in this
catastrophe so there are exceptions to
this but in general the fossil record
only shows us the most common organisms
at a given time which means that their
actual evolution their their first
emergence happened much earlier than
what the fossil record shows us James
says stated clearly we now have a
dinosaur called Thanos that is awesome I
did not know that
yeah Shannon's reminding everyone makes
sure to put at stated clearly and your
comment so that I can tell that it's an
actual question rather than comment just
random comments cuz there's a lot of
people today
chatting I think that that does it for
questions right now Oh someone some says
that the Audubon Society says that there
are nearly 20,000 bird species now so
yeah some of this is debatable you know
art are these two groups of birds a
species should we qualify them as a
species or not there's a huge
controversy going on in Oregon right now
as to whether or not he spotted out
really is a species or if it's just a
subpopulation of barred owls but and the
reason that's a huge debate is because
the spotted owl isn't is on the
endangered species list but it can mate
happily with barred owls so people are
saying it shouldn't belong in the
endangered species list because it's not
really a species yeah
it's a there's a lot of controversy
around how even count species but yes we
are rapidly increasing the number of
bird species that we know about for
several reasons one is which we're
getting better at defining species or
people have more agreement on how
species are defined now than they used
to even there's still a lot of argument
and then we have people love birding so
we're really good at identifying bird
species
someone just posted 379 375 million
years ago is the date that we have for
Tiktaalik so thank you Sebastian
all right well I think that sums up
today's lesson it was fun it was fun it
was fun going through and finding how
people are using math to confuse people
not only in the creationist literature
but also on Facebook and it was funny
how quickly I was able to find those two
Facebook arguments so and and we found
that even top-notch researchers that
spend their life studying statistics and
analyzing data do the same they screw up
how to use numbers to come to
conclusions it super easy to do so I
guess the moral of the story is when
someone proves their point with math
they didn't actually prove their point
with math you need to be very careful
and look at all the reasoning behind
that the proof that they're providing
and particularly ask yourself are these
all of the variables that we need to
consider are these variables legitimate
variables to be using at all and by
answering those questions you can come
to to see whether or not someone's
mathematical argument really is
legitimate or if it's garbage and I'll
tell you that the majority are garbage
one last example that I want to tell you
that that I a friend of mine a teaches
high school biology made there was a
study a while back by NIH that
discovered that in the human body there
are roughly ten times more bacteria than
there are human cells and my friend was
teaching his students that you are
mostly bacteria you know he extrapolated
from those numbers you know one out of
ten cells is human the rest are
bacterial well he was extrapolating that
to say that you are mostly bacteria that
is wrong because bacteria are tiny
bacterial cells are tiny compared to
human cells and the actual
of bacteria is about somewhere between
two to six pounds and a 200-pound adult
male so between two and six pounds are
bacteria even though they outnumber our
human cells by a dramatic number so he
came to the wrong conclusion and was
teaching that to his students because it
seemed to make sense given the the
numbers that he had had been looking at
he he failed to look at the other
relevant numbers and that and that
problem and we do this all the time
I guarantee that I believe things that
are false because of math problems I
guarantee that you believe things that
are false because of math problems it is
super easy to do so be careful ladies
and gentlemen as you go forth and your
studies of how the world works because
math can screw you up so long for now
stay curious